Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory. all eyes to the throne. Suddenly two or three run, others fall back. Some talk, direct, hurry, stand still or disappear. Then three or four of high rank appear from behind the throne. An interval is left. The crowd scarce breathe.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列内容并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问therestishistory。所有的目光都投向了王座。突然，两三个人跑开了，其他人退了回来。有些人说话、指挥、催促、伫立原地或消失不见。随后，三四位显贵从王座后方出现。空出了一个间隔。人群甚至不敢呼吸。
Something rustles, and a being buried in satin, feathers, and diamonds rolls gracefully into his seat. The room rises with a sort of feathered silken thunder. Plumes wave, eyes sparkle, glasses are out, mouths smile, and one man becomes the prime object of attraction to thousands. The way in which the king bowed was monarchic. As he looked towards the peeresses and foreign ambassadors, he looked like some gorgeous bird of the East. So that, Dominic, was a description by the painter Benjamin Robert Hayden of George IV entering Westminster Abbey for his coronation, with very much an emphasis on the rolling.
有什么东西发出了沙沙声，一个被淹没在缎子、羽毛和钻石之中的人优雅地滚进了他的座位。整个房间伴随着一种仿佛插满羽毛的丝绸般的雷鸣声站了起来。羽饰挥舞，目光闪烁，眼镜纷纷戴上，嘴角带着微笑，而一个人成为了成千上万人的绝对焦点。国王鞠躬的方式充满君王风范。当他望向女贵族和外国大使时，他看起来就像某种华丽的东方飞鸟。多米尼克，那是画家本杰明·罗伯特·海顿对乔治四世进入威斯敏斯特教堂参加加冕典礼的描述，其中非常强调那个“滚”字。
Yes. Because he was a very large gentleman, wasn't he? He was a man of size. And I've read that from Roy Strong's book, Coronation, A History of Kingship in the British Monarchy. And it actually has George IV on the cover. He's got a train. I think he's wearing a kind of cloak modelled on Napoleon's.
没错。因为他是一位非常富态的绅士，不是吗？他是一个体型庞大的人。我是从罗伊·斯特朗的《加冕礼：英国君主制王权史》一书中读到这一段的。那本书的封面正好就是乔治四世。他拖着一条长袍。我想他穿的那种斗篷是仿照拿破仑的款式制作的。
Only designed to be even bigger and better. And there are eight people carrying it. His coronation was an absolutely splendid occasion, Tom. It was simultaneously vulgar and shambolic, wasn't it? It was. And incredibly, incredibly expensive. Yes. So all themes that we will be exploring over this the final episode of
只是被设计得更大、更华丽。而且有八个人在后面帮他托着。他的加冕典礼绝对是一个极其盛大的场合，汤姆。它既粗俗又混乱，对吧？确实如此。而且贵得离谱、难以置信。是的。所以，这些都是我们将在此次探讨的主题，也就是我们关于
our tour through coronations um and in the the second episode we finished with um the last of the stewarts and dying and she is succeeded by george the first who is the um who comes from hanover yeah and he's chosen basically for one reason and one reason only, namely that he's not Catholic. Exactly. He's a Protestant. So he doesn't really even speak English, which as we shall see- Leads to complications. Leads to complications of the coronation.
加冕典礼之旅的最后一集。嗯，在第二集里，我们以斯图亚特王朝的最后一位君主驾崩结束，她由乔治一世继位，他是一位……他来自汉诺威，对吧？而他被选中基本上只有一个原因，而且是唯一的理由，那就是他不是天主教徒。没错。他是一位新教徒。所以他甚至不会说英语，正如我们所见——这导致了种种麻烦。导致了加冕典礼上的麻烦。
So in that very first episode, Tom, you did that brilliant bit of historical kind of detective work, uncovering the sort of Christian roots, the roots in the Old Testament, paganism, Anglo-Saxon kings, the Carolingians, Charlemagne. And you made coronation seem deeply important and powerful. Beating sacral heart of a kingdom. Right. But when you get to the Hanoverians... It all gets tits up. Well, yeah, it's just... There's just a series of... I mean, one of them is actually very good, I think, George II. The others are ludicrous in all kinds of entertaining ways.
所以在第一集里，汤姆，你做了极其精彩的历史侦探工作，揭示了那种基督教的根源、旧约中的根源、异教、盎格鲁-撒克逊国王、加洛林王朝、查理曼大帝。你让加冕典礼显得意义非凡且充满力量。这是一个王国的神圣核心。没错。但当你来到汉诺威王朝时……一切都搞砸了。嗯，是的，这简直……这只是一连串的……我是说，其中有一位其实非常不错，我认为，那就是乔治二世。其他的则以各种搞笑的方式显得荒唐可笑。
There's a sense in which they don't understand really what's going on, isn't there? Yeah. Well, George I literally doesn't understand what's going on, because he's German and he doesn't really speak English. So basically, he had become king on the 1st of August 1714 because that's when Queen Anne had died. And that had been preceded by all kinds of political jostling. Are the Hanoverians going to come in? Is it more important to have a very remote Protestant relative than to go to the Catholic Stuarts or Jacobites? They basically decide, fine, we'll get George over. He pitches up in September, and then he's crowned in October.
某种程度上，他们根本不明白发生了什么，对吧？是的。嗯，乔治一世字面意义上就不明白发生了什么，因为他是德国人，而且他真的不会说英语。所以基本上，他是在1714年8月1日成为国王的，因为那是安妮女王去世的日子。在此之前，经历了各种政治博弈。汉诺威人会入主吗？拥有一位极其疏远的信奉新教的亲戚，是不是比去找天主教的斯图亚特王朝或詹姆斯党人更重要？他们基本上决定，好吧，我们把乔治接过来。他在九月份抵达，然后于十月份加冕。
So because he doesn't speak any English, they agree that they'll go back to doing it in Latin, so that actually he will have some vague sense of what is going on. And so this is the first time since Elizabeth, isn't it? Since Elizabeth, exactly. What's slightly shambolic is that the Archbishop of Canterbury, Thomas Tennyson, he's 78 and he's completely doddery and inept. So adding to the fun. Everything goes wrong. A bit like what we talked about, James I came down from Scotland, huge security because
所以因为他不会说任何英语，他们同意恢复使用拉丁语来举行仪式，这样他实际上就能对正在发生的事情有个模模糊糊的概念。这也是自伊丽莎白女王以来第一次这样做，对吧？自伊丽莎白以来，确实如此。稍微有点混乱的是，坎特伯雷大主教托马斯·滕森已经78岁了，而且完全老糊涂、昏庸无能。这就增添了更多的乐趣。一切都出了岔子。有点像我们谈到过的，詹姆斯一世从苏格兰南下时，由于
people are worried about ructions. So there's huge security this time. And actually the bishops of Bath and wells and durham who you talked about i think in the first or second episode has always been key figures they they're not able to get to the king's canopy where he's meant to be because there's too many soldiers around who sort of push them out of the way and stuff what would say dunstan say well so dunstan would not be impressed no um there's a point at which actually if it's the last coronation in which the Archbishop of Canterbury asks the congregation sort of formulaically, do you accept this man as your new king? And one of the people there is a woman called Catherine Sedley, who is the former
人们担心发生骚乱而实施了极其严格的安保。所以这次安保也非常严密。实际上，巴斯与韦尔斯以及达勒姆的主教们——你在第一集或第二集里提到过他们，他们一直都是关键人物——他们根本无法靠近国王的华盖，也就是他理应呆的地方，因为周围有太多的士兵，把他们推来搡去之类的。邓斯坦会怎么说呢？好吧，邓斯坦肯定不会留下好印象，不，嗯，有那么一刻，实际上——这是坎特伯雷大主教最后一次以程式化的方式向会众询问：“你们是否接受这个人作为你们的新王？”而当时在场的人中有一位名叫凯瑟琳·西德利的女性，她是詹姆斯二世的前
mistress of James II, and she's renowned as a great wit. And she says, when the Archbishop asks this question, she apparently said in a very loud voice, does that old fool think that anyone here will say no to his question when there are so many drawn swords? So it's very much a sort of cross between the coronation and a kind of armed camp. And actually, the drawn swords are completely understandable because this is the year of the great coronation riots. So in at least 20 towns across England, largely in the South and the West. So in other words, those parts of the country that actually had been pretty royalist in the Civil War, if you look at the map. The Coronation Day sees tremendous riots by sort of Tory mobs.
情妇，以绝妙的机智而闻名。当大主教提出这个问题时，据说她用极大的声音说道：“那个老糊涂难道认为，在有这么多拔出鞘的宝剑的情况下，这里会有人对他的问题说不吗？”所以这在很大程度上有点介于加冕典礼和武装军营之间。事实上，拔出鞘的宝剑完全是可以理解的，因为这是发生伟大加冕骚乱的一年。英格兰至少有20个城镇爆发了骚乱，主要集中在南部和西部。换句话说，如果你看地图的话，正是那些在内战中相当支持保王党的地区。加冕日当天，托利党暴徒发起了规模惊人的骚乱。
It's fair to say. If you can imagine a Tory mob. High church mobs, Tom. So I know we have a lot of vicars and people of the cloth who listen to this podcast drawn by your work on Christianity. And we also have at least one listener
这么说很公平。如果你能想象一个托利党暴徒的话。高教会派暴徒，汤姆。所以我知道有很多牧师和神职人员因为你对基督教的研究而收听这个播客。我们还有一个听众
to this podcast who lambasts us on Twitter whenever he suspects us of wiggery or of low church sentiments or any tolerance of dissent or any of these kinds of things. So they would have been out rioting? They absolutely would have been out rioting because there had recently been a huge hullabaloo, one of the great political controversies in all British history, about a man called Henry Sir Cheverell,
每当他怀疑我们带有辉格党色彩、低教会派情绪、对异见有任何宽容或任何此类倾向时，就会在推特上痛斥我们。所以他们会出去暴乱吗？他们绝对会出去暴乱，因为最近刚刚发生了一场巨大的喧嚣，这是英国历史上最大的政治争议之一，主角是一个名叫亨利·萨切弗尔的男子，
who had given this sermon in which he dissed dissenters and low church people. And he'd been impeached by the House of Commons. And this had been the single biggest issue in the general election of 1710. Great days. Great days. Great days. So the mobs pour onto the streets on Coronation Day. In Bristol, they shout,
他发表了一场布道，在其中贬低异见者和低教会派人士。他被下议院弹劾了。这成为了1710年大选中单一最大的议题。好日子。好日子。好日子。于是，暴徒们在加冕日涌上街头。在布里斯托尔，他们高喊：
Sir Cheverell and the Duke of Ormond and damn all foreigners. Great slogans. In Taunton, Church and Dr. Sir Cheverell. In Birmingham, Tom, I know you're an Aston Villa supporter, they chant, kill the old rogue, by which they mean George I, kill them all, Sir Cheverell forever. In Tewkesbury, Sir Cheverell forever, down with the roundheads. Great stuff.
“萨切弗尔和奥蒙德公爵万岁，去死吧，所有外国人。”绝佳的口号。在汤顿：“教会与萨切弗尔博士万岁。”在伯明翰，汤姆，我知道你是阿斯顿维拉的球迷，他们高呼：“杀死那个老恶棍”（他们指的是乔治一世），“把他们赶尽杀绝，萨切弗尔万岁”。在蒂克斯伯里：“萨切弗尔万岁，打倒圆颅党。”太棒了。
All this sort of stuff. So there's a lot of trouble. There's not enough troops to kind of suppress it. So the mobs kind of rage, rampage, unchecked. But that's a good coronation tradition, going back at least to the time of William the Conqueror. You'd like to see, well, yes. Well, except in William the Conqueror,
诸如此类的事情。所以有很多麻烦。没有足够的军队来镇压它。因此，暴徒们肆虐、横行，无人阻拦。但这倒是个不错的加冕传统，至少可以追溯到征服者威廉的时代。你很想看到……嗯，是的。好吧，除了在征服者威廉的加冕礼上，
the mob, I mean, there are lots of soldiers who do a lot of damage, aren't there? I mean, every side could join. Because presumably there are people who are very keen on George I as well. Whigs. Yes. You know, he's saving Britain from the maxims of French tyranny and the principles of Popish superstition.
暴徒——我是说，有很多士兵造成了巨大的破坏，不是吗？我是说，各方都可以加入。因为大概也有很多人非常支持乔治一世。辉格党人。是的。你知道，他正在把英国从法国暴政的信条和天主教迷信的原则中拯救出来。
I suppose. So there's also the whole issue of maypoles. So the maypole is regarded by this point as a symbol of Jacobitism, of incipient Jacobitism. That's a great shame, isn't it? Because... Because it should be a symbol of merry England. Well, you see, this is the thing. It's seen as a symbol of merry England.
我想是的。所以这里还有五月柱的整个问题。因此，五月柱到这个时候被视为雅各布派主义、萌芽中的雅各布派主义的象征。这真是太遗憾了，不是吗？因为……因为它本该是快乐英格兰的象征。好吧，你看，这就是问题所在。它被视为快乐英格兰的象征。
And people say, oh, the roundheads hated maypoles in the 1650s. And the Whigs, if they're not challenged, they will eventually get rid of maypoles. And George I is merely a Trojan horse for anti-maypolism. It's for anti-fun. Exactly. Exactly. So people are still shouting and rampaging about. And in Bedford, they actually dress the maypole in mourning in black.
人们说，哦，圆颅党人在16世纪50年代恨透了五月柱。而辉格党人如果不受到挑战，他们最终会除掉五月柱。乔治一世不过是反五月柱主义的一个特洛伊木马。这是为了反对快乐。绝对是。绝对是。所以人们仍然在到处呐喊和横行霸道。在贝德福德，他们甚至给五月柱穿上了黑色的丧服。
Do you know, I love Hanoverian England. All of this stuff. Well, it's, they actually dress the Maypole in mourning in black. Do you know, I love Hanoverian England. All of this stuff. Well, it's all these memories of the Civil War. Yeah. I mean, the fact that people are going and rioting, shouting about
你知道吗，我太喜欢汉诺威时期的英国了。所有这些乱七八糟的事。好吧，实际上他们给五月柱穿上了黑色的丧服。你知道吗，我太喜欢汉诺威时期的英国了。所有这些乱七八糟的事。好吧，这全都是关于内战的记忆。是的。我的意思是，人们到处暴乱，高喊着
high church forever. The thing I liked about George I as someone who's recently become a Scottish landowner. Yeah. Inherited this tiny little place outside Berwick-on-Tweed.
高教会派万岁。作为一个最近刚成为苏格兰地主的人，我喜欢乔治一世的一点是——是的。继承了特威德河畔贝里克外的一个极小的地方。
I'm glad you described it because whenever you say you've become a Scottish landowner, I imagine a lot of people unsubscribing in horror. Owning Ben Nevis or something. No, it's a little crofter's cottage on the banks of the Tweed. And he was crowned as king of the kingdoms of England, Scotland, Ireland, and France, the Dominion of Wales, and the town of Berwick-on-Tweed.
我很高兴你描述了它，因为每当你宣称自己成了苏格兰地主时，我总觉得会有很多人惊恐地取消订阅。仿佛你拥有了本尼维斯山什么的。不，那是特威德河畔的一座小农舍。而他加冕为英格兰、苏格兰、爱尔兰和法兰西王国、威尔士领地以及贝里克-特威德镇的国王。
It's a separate entity. It's a separate entity. Very good. Very good. That's good. So this rioting, actually, it then flares up again in 1715, a year later at the general election, which is won by the Whigs, and they then pass the Riot Act.
这是一个独立的实体。这是一个独立的实体。非常好。非常好。这很好。所以这场骚乱，实际上，在1715年又爆发了，也就是一年后的大选期间，大选中辉格党获胜，随后他们通过了《暴动法》。
So the phrase that's very common. Ah, okay, so read the Riot Act. To read the Riot Act is that the troops would read it out, or somebody, a magistrate or whatever, would read it out to people if they don't disperse. Well, there you go. The Whigs stopping innocent people from having fun. Cracking down on rioting.
所以这是一个非常常见的短语。啊，好吧，也就是“宣读《暴动法》”。宣读《暴动法》的意思是，军队会将其宣读出来，或者某个地方法官之类的人，如果人们不散去的话，就会向人群宣读它。好了，你看。辉格党阻止无辜的人享受乐趣。打击骚乱。
Right, exactly. So that's George I's coronation. The coronation itself is a slight, it's not that exciting compared with the rioting. George II's coronation. That's splendid, isn't it? Because that's the handle one. That's the Zadok the priest one. Exactly, exactly.
对，完全正确。这就是乔治一世的加冕礼。加冕典礼本身其实稍微有点……与骚乱相比，它并不是那么令人兴奋。乔治二世的加冕典礼。那场面很宏大，不是吗？因为那是亨德尔配乐的那场。那是伴有亨德尔音乐的。绝对的，绝对的。
So George II's coronation, I think, is actually a real high point of coronations. It's the handle one. Exactly. Exactly. So George II's coronation, I think, is actually a real high point of coronations. It actually goes well. Nothing goes chaotically wrong. Doesn't his queen wear a spectacularly
所以乔治二世的加冕礼，我认为，实际上是加冕典礼的一个真正的高潮。那是亨德尔配乐的那场。绝对的。绝对的。所以乔治二世的加冕礼，我认为，其实是加冕典礼的真正巅峰。一切都进展顺利。没有什么乱七八糟的意外发生。他的王后是不是穿着一件极其
ornamented dress? She does with jewels. With jewels. So many jewels that they have to lift her up by a pulley when she kneels down. Yeah.
华丽的饰裙？她确实穿着，上面镶满了珠宝。镶满了珠宝。珠宝多到当她跪下时，人们不得不靠滑轮把她吊起来。是的。
So she's kind of weighed down by the weight of rubies or whatever. It'd be nice to see that at the king's, wouldn't it? That would very would answer the critics of she's also given we know that her mistress of the robes had a handkerchief to wipe off any oil that might foil and fall on her face so that suggests to me that at this point in the anointing they're slightly more concerned about its sartorial implications yeah and they are about the sacral quality. Well, because it must be really difficult because essentially as Protestants who are
所以她基本上是被红宝石之类的重量给压垮了。如果在国王的加冕典礼上看到这一幕就好了，不是吗？那绝对能回击那些批评者的声音。我们还知道，她的掌衣女官曾备有一块手帕，用来擦去任何可能弄脏并掉落在她脸上的圣油，所以这向我表明，在此时的涂油礼中，他们对服装搭配的影响的关心，要略微超过
also very, you know, the spirit of enlightenment is going on. It's all that kind of thing. I mean, it must be very weird that these rituals are still carrying, still being done. Also, there's a lot of German blood in this coronation and they're very practical people, the Germans. They are, aren't they? Hence the provision of handkerchiefs. Also, hence the provision, at this point,
对神圣属性的关心。嗯，因为这一定很难，本质上作为新教徒，他们
putting aside seats in Westminster Abbey for people to sell wine and coffee during the ceremony. And do you think kind of portable toilets? There are toilets put aside, and toilets will become an issue later in this podcast, Tom, you'll be pleased to hear. Amazing. I'll tell you who's still around at this coronation
同时又非常……启蒙运动的精神正在进行中。全都是诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，这些仪式居然还在继续，还在举行，这一定非常诡异。此外，这次加冕典礼中有很多德国血统，德国人是非常务实的人。他们确实是，对吧？因此才会提供手帕。同样也是出于这个原因，在这个时候，
and gets a laugh from the crowd. Sarah Churchill, the Duchess of Marlborough. So the former favourite of Queen Anne. She's still around. The procession goes on a very long time and it's very boring apparently. So she took a drum from one of the drummers and sat on it. And people said, oh, that's the wife of the Duke of Marlborough. And they all cheered and laughed and thought this was hilarious. QA would have enjoyed that, wouldn't he? He would, yeah. And there, Sarah Churchill, elegant Duchess of Posteria. Exactly. So we know that actually this was an impressive occasion because there was a Swiss traveler called César de Souciere. And he went to a lot of this and reported on it.
在威斯敏斯特教堂里留出座位，供人在仪式期间出售葡萄酒和咖啡。你觉得是不是还有便携式厕所？确实留出了厕所的位置，而且稍后在这个播客里厕所会成为一个问题，汤姆，你一定会高兴听到这点的。太棒了。我来告诉你谁在这个加冕典礼上依然健在，并且博得了人群的一笑。萨拉·丘吉尔，马尔巴罗公爵夫人。也就是安妮女王曾经最宠爱的人。她依然健在。游行队伍持续了很长时间，而且显然非常无聊。于是她从一个鼓手那里拿了一个鼓，然后坐在上面。人们说：“哦，那是马尔巴罗公爵夫人。”他们都欢呼大笑，觉得这滑稽极了。安妮女王一定会喜欢这个的，对吧？她会的，是的。还有，萨拉·丘吉尔，优雅的后排公爵夫人。没错。所以我们知道，实际上这是一个令人印象深刻的场面，因为有一位名叫塞萨尔·德·苏西尔的瑞士旅行者。他参加了其中很多活动并对此进行了报道。
How come? Did he buy a ticket? Are they selling tickets? Well, they do sell tickets. They sell tickets to the banquet. Oh, but not to the ceremony in the Abbey? No, not to the ceremony. He was very impressed by the banquet.
怎么回事？他买票了吗？他们当时卖票吗？嗯，他们确实卖票。他们把宴会的票卖了。哦，但不是威斯敏斯特教堂里仪式的票？不，不是仪式的票。他对宴会印象深刻。
He said the chandeliers were very good. He said there's a hereditary champion. We haven't talked about the king's champion. The champion always comes in on horseback during the banquet in full armour. And this Swiss fellow thought this was absolutely brilliant. Well, it would be, wouldn't it? I'm amazed that Charles hasn't brought that back.
他说枝形吊灯非常漂亮。他说这里有一位世袭的国王捍卫者。我们还没聊到国王的捍卫者。捍卫者总是穿着全套盔甲在宴会期间骑马入场。这位瑞士朋友认为这绝对棒极了。嗯，确实会很棒，不是吗？我很惊讶查尔斯没有把这个恢复过来。
Yeah, that would be fantastic. He loves a retro stunt stump doesn't he charles is very keen on the music and this is the musical coronation because handle had been brought over under george i uh one of the george i's last bits of legislation was an act to naturalize handle as a british citizen so handle is given the job of writing the music. He has four weeks to do it, and he writes Zadok the Priest, which is the Champions League anthem, or the genesis thereof, that we started our series with. And everybody immediately thinks it's brilliant.
是的，那太棒了。他喜欢复古特技秀，不是吗？查尔斯对音乐非常热衷，这就是那场音乐加冕礼，因为亨德尔是在乔治一世统治时期被请到英国来的，呃，乔治一世最后的立法之一就是一项将亨德尔归化为英国公民的法案。所以亨德尔得到了为加冕礼谱曲的工作。他只有四周的时间来完成，他写出了《萨多克祭司》，也就是我们系列节目开篇时听到的那个欧冠主题曲，或者说是它的雏形。每个人都立刻觉得它棒极了。
The only thing that goes wrong is that actually at the coronation, the choir sang Zadok the Priest at the wrong point. They'd gotten a terrible muddle with it and they'd sung the wrong words at one point and done some anthem and forgotten to do the end. So they sing this at the wrong point. But apart from that, it's brilliant. Wasn't there a problem with the choir boys as well, that their voices kept breaking in the rehearsal? Oh no. So they had to cut, you know, kind of hurling fresh choir boys in to take them places.
唯一出岔子的地方在于，实际上在加冕典礼上，唱诗班在错误的时间唱了《萨多克祭司》。他们在曲子上搞得一团糟，在某个地方唱错了歌词，唱成了别的赞美诗，却忘了唱结尾。所以他们在错误的时间唱了这首歌。但除此之外，它棒极了。唱诗班的男孩们是不是也出了问题，他们的声音在排练时不断变声？哦，没有。所以他们不得不临时撤换，你知道的，不断把新鲜的唱诗班男孩扔上去顶替。
Right. But the sense I get is that it's a kind of cycle of shambolic, expertly organised, shambolic, expertly organised. And so it goes on. Well, I think we've got two shambolics in a row, actually. George III is... George III is an idea. An absolute idea. Well, George IV is pretty bad.
对。但给我的感觉是，这是一个类似“混乱、专业组织、混乱、专业组织”的循环。然后就这样一直继续下去。嗯，我想我们接下来连续遇到了两次混乱，实际上。乔治三世是……乔治三世简直是个绝妙的主意。绝对是个奇葩。嗯，乔治四世也挺糟糕的。
George III is an idea. So they set up 1761. They're learning from, what is it, about 30 years, just over 30 years since George II's coronation. They do the same. They're going to have a big banquet in Westminster Hall. They've got partitions. They've got a sluice, and I quote,
乔治三世真是个活宝。所以他们在1761年筹备。他们从——距离乔治二世的加冕典礼大约30年、刚过30年——吸取了经验。他们照章办事。他们要在威斯敏斯特大厅举办一场盛大的宴会。他们设置了隔断。他们修建了一条排水沟，引述原话，
for the reception of urinary discharges. They've got, they sort out galleries and stuff in Westminster Abbey. However, everything else is rubbish and totally shambolically and disastrously organised. So to start with, crowds are too big and there are too many people trying to get to Westminster Abbey in carriages and there's a carriage jam outside Westminster Abbey. So they can't, people can't get into the Abbey. Everything is massively delayed. They finally get into the Abbey, and the person who is organizing it, who is, what's his name?
“用于接收尿液排放物”。他们在威斯敏斯特教堂里搭建了看台之类的东西。然而，其他所有事情都是垃圾，而且在组织上完全混乱且灾难百出。首先，人群实在太多，有太多人试图坐马车去威斯敏斯特教堂，导致威斯敏斯特教堂外面发生了马车大堵车。所以他们根本进不去，人们进不了教堂。一切都严重延误。他们好不容易进了教堂，而负责组织的那个人，他叫什么名字？
The Earl of Effingham, I think it is, or something of Effingham. They're aptly named. He's forgotten loads of the stuff. He's forgotten the thrones, hasn't he? He's forgotten, yeah, there's nowhere for the king and queen to sit. He's forgotten the sword of state, so they have to borrow a sword, a random sword from the Lord Mayor of London. The canopy is a big deal for people in 18th century coronations.
埃芬汉姆伯爵，我想是吧，或者埃芬汉姆的什么人。他们的名字起得真贴切。他落下了大堆东西。他把王座给忘了，对吧？他忘了……是的，国王和王后根本没有地方坐。他忘了国剑，所以他们不得不借一把剑，从伦敦市长那里随便借了一把剑。对于18世纪加冕典礼中的人们来说，华盖是一件大事。
They've forgotten the canopy, so they have to sort of try and cobble something together with a bit of cloth and some sticks. So this obviously looks awful, looks rubbish. The crowds are so thick, they're sort of pressing down. There's not enough troops to hold back the crowds. So the troops are having to beat back the crowds with the flats of their swords and the butts of their muskets. So this is obviously not very, you know, it's not the sort of spirit of jollity.
他们把华盖给忘了，所以他们不得不临时用一块布和几根棍子拼凑出一个勉强能用的东西。所以这显然看起来糟透了，像个垃圾。人群太拥挤了，他们一直在往前挤。没有足够的军队来阻挡人群。因此，士兵们不得不挥舞着未开刃的剑和平民步枪的枪托来击退人群。所以这显然很不……你知道的，这根本不是什么欢乐的精神。
It's not sacral at all. I mean, to have forgotten the thrones is ludicrous behaviour. All the spectators who write accounts. So whereas the Swiss fellow said, brilliant, 1727, people now say they talk of always confusion, irregularity and disorder. There's a lawyer, isn't there? William Hickey. Oh, right.
一点也不神圣。我的意思是，居然把王座给忘掉，这简直是荒谬绝伦的行为。所有写下记录的旁观者都这么说。所以，如果说那位瑞士人在1727年还觉得“太棒了”的话，人们现在却开始谈论“永远的混乱、无序和失控”。有一个律师，对吧？威廉·希基。哦，对了。
Yes, it's William Hickey there. Yeah. Who gives his account of the anointing. Yeah. It's very funny. As many thousands were out of the possibility of hearing a single syllable, they took that opportunity to eat their meal when the general clattering of knives, forks, plates, and glasses that ensued produced a most ridiculous effect and a universal bout of laughter for them.
是的，威廉·希基也在场。是的。他记录了涂油礼的过程。是的。非常搞笑。由于成千上万的人根本不可能听清哪怕一个音节，他们便趁机开始吃起了随身携带的餐点，随之而来的刀叉、盘子和玻璃杯的普遍碰撞声产生了极其滑稽的效果，引发了在场人员的一阵普遍大笑。
That's right. They've all brought in picnics. People have all brought in picnics. I think this reflects very well on Hanoverian Britain. On pies and stuff. Well, it seems they're either rioting or picnicking. I mean, that's exactly how I think of the 18th century. They keep having to stop because nobody knows what's meant to happen.
没错。他们全都自带了野餐。人们全都带了野餐。我觉得这很好地反映了汉诺威时期的英国风貌。带着馅饼之类的东西。嗯，看起来他们要么在暴乱，要么在野餐。我的意思是，这就是我对18世纪的精确印象。他们不得不频频停下来，因为根本没人知道接下来该发生什么。
What to do. So at one point, the king's meant to take communion, and he doesn't know whether he should wear his crown or not. But they obviously haven't been rehearsing enough. No, they've done no rehearsal. So here's where you've got a toilet issue. They've set up a special toilet, which they call the retiring chamber,
该做什么。所以在某个时刻，国王本该领圣餐，但他不知道自己是该戴着王冠还是不该戴。显然他们排练得远远不够。不，他们根本没排练。所以这里就遇到了厕所问题。他们特意搭建了一个厕所，他们称之为“更衣室”，
for the Queen to use behind the high altar instead of the chapel. When she gets there... What goes wrong? She sneaks off to go to the loo. When she gets there, she finds the Duke of Newcastle. It's like a man who's using the ladies. You know, that kind of... The Duke of Newcastle. It's like a man who's using the ladies, you know, that kind of...
供王后在圣坛后面使用，而不是去小圣堂。当她走到那里时……出什么事了？她偷偷溜去上厕所。当她到达那里时，她发现纽卡斯尔公爵正在里面。这就像是一个男人误入了女厕所。你知道，那种……纽卡斯尔公爵。这就像是一个男人用了女厕所，你知道，那种……
The Duke of Newcastle has taken advantage of... Self-identifying for a few minutes. Right. And is sitting and is seated on the clothes stool, as they call it, which must be a very unpalatable sight in the middle of a coronation. Especially if he's eating a pie at the same time. Right. Sound of cutlery, meanwhile, and people laughing.
纽卡斯尔公爵利用了……自认女性的几分钟。对。并且正坐在——或者说坐在他们所谓的便桶上，这在加冕典礼的正中央绝对是一个极不雅观的景象。尤其是如果他当时还在吃馅饼的话。对。与此同时，餐具碰撞的声音，以及人们的笑声。
So... Sounds great. The whole thing takes six hours. And by the time they get out, it's taken so long that it's all... The sound of cutlery, meanwhile, and people laughing. Sounds great. The whole thing takes six hours. And by the time they get out, it's taken so long that it's dark. On the way back, the king complains to this bloke Effingham and says, this was awful. This was a disaster. This was my big day and it's been a disaster.
所以……听起来很棒。整个过程持续了六个小时。等他们出来的时候，已经花了太长时间，以至于全都……与此同时，餐具碰撞的声音伴随着人们的笑声。听起来很棒。整个过程持续了六个小时。等他们出来的时候，时间长得天都黑了。在回去的路上，国王向这个叫埃芬汉姆的家伙抱怨说：“这太糟了。这简直是一场灾难。这是我的人生大日子，结果却成了一场灾难。”
And Effingham says to him, you know, I grant you there has been some neglect. But he says, the good news is we've learned lessons and the next coronation will be really well organized. That's what you want. And George III apparently found this highly amusing. He went back and had bread and milk with his wife, didn't he? Well, actually, the coronation banquet, Tom, if that's a shambles, the coronation banquet is possibly even worse. So to start with, they light this by these linen tapers. And the linen tapers shower the guests with ash.
而埃芬汉姆对他说：“我知道，我承认其中确实有一些疏忽。”但他说，“好消息是我们已经吸取了教训，下一次加冕典礼一定能组织得非常好。”这正是你梦寐以求的话。而乔治三世显然觉得这极其滑稽。他回去和他的妻子一起吃了面包和牛奶，对吧？嗯，事实上，汤姆，如果说加冕典礼是一团糟的话，那么加冕晚宴可能还要更糟糕。首先，他们用亚麻烛芯来点灯。而亚麻烛芯把灰烬洒落在宾客身上。
So everybody is covered in ash. The organization, the thing is organized by a bloke called William Talbot, who's the Lord Steward. And he is, I read, was noted for his swaggering manners and rude demeanor. And he's forgotten to put in enough tables. So there's two groups, the barons of the sink ports and the aldermen of the city of London. And there's no seats for them at all. The aldermen are given the table of the knights of the bath and they're kicked out.
于是每个人身上都覆盖了一层灰烬。整场活动的组织者是一个叫威廉·塔尔伯特的人，他是宫廷总管。我读到过，他以傲慢的姿态和粗鲁的举止而闻名。他竟然忘记摆放足够多的桌子了。于是分成了两拨人，辛克港的男爵们和伦敦市的参事们。结果他们根本没有座位。参事们被安排坐到了巴斯骑士的桌子上，然后被赶了出去。
The barons of the sink ports have no table at all. they're told they just have to i hope they riot no uh they're only silenced when this bloke william talbot challenges them to a duel excellent so meanwhile he has trained his horse he's got a party trick he's trained his horse to walk backwards away from the king as a sign of you know respect like a sort of yeah like a persian vizier yeah you know retreating from his sovereign but the horse gets it wrong and keeps backing keeps backing towards the king and whenever they put so showing the king his ass and presumably dumping whenever they shove the horse out they managed to get the horse out of westminster hall the horse keeps forcing its way back in and backing towards the king. Oh, it sounds great.
辛克港的男爵们甚至连一张桌子都没有。他们被告知只能——我真希望他们闹事。不，呃，直到这个叫威廉·塔尔伯特的家伙向他们发起决斗，他们才闭嘴。太棒了！与此同时，他训练了自己的马，他有一个绝活，他训练马在离开国王时倒退着走，以此来表示（你知道的）尊敬，就像某种——是的，就像一个波斯维齐尔——是的，你知道的，从他的君主面前退下——但那匹马搞砸了，一直往后退，一直在向国王倒退，每当他们把马——也就是向国王展示马屁股，大概还会随地大小便——每当他们把马赶出威斯敏斯特大厅，这匹马又会强行挤回来，继续倒退着走向国王。哦，听起来太棒了。
So it finally ends at 10 o'clock and the banquet ends. And actually what happens here is not unique to 1761. It happens at almost all of these banquets. As soon as it ends, the tradition is that the public can then have whatever is left. So there are people outside and in the galleries who are poised waiting for the last guest to leave. Is it like the Christmas sales? Right. But their face is pressed to the glass.
所以晚宴终于在10点钟结束了。而且，发生在这里的事情并非1761年独有。几乎所有这些晚宴上都会发生这种情况。一旦晚宴结束，按传统，公众就可以拿走剩下的任何东西。所以外面和看台上到处都是人，他们摩拳擦掌，等着最后一位宾客离开。这就像是圣诞节大促销吗？对。但他们的脸紧紧贴着玻璃。
And as soon as that happens, it's all up for grabs and they pile in. So they pile in and they take everything. They'll take the tablecloths. They take chairs. They'll take the tablecloths, they take chairs, they take plates, and this sort of mob storming off with all this stuff. And because it's regarded as traditional, nobody wants to be the person who stops it. So it continues. Now, do you think we have time for George IV before the break? Yes, I think we absolutely do. Just one note. Yes. Did you read this thing about
一旦那一刻到来，所有东西都成了抢手货，他们一拥而上。所以他们一拥而上，抢走了一切。他们会拿走桌布。他们拿走椅子。他们拿走桌布，拿走椅子，拿走盘子，诸如此类的暴民带着所有这些东西冲了出去。而且因为这被视为传统，没有人想当那个制止它的人。于是这种情况一直在继续。现在，你觉得我们在中场休息前还有时间讲讲乔治四世吗？是的，我想我们绝对有时间。只有一个小注解。是的。你读到过关于
Bonnie Prince Charlie perhaps coming? I didn't. Surely he would not have been welcome. Well, apparently he attended the coronation under the pseudonym of Mr. Yes. Did you read this thing about Bonnie Prince Charlie perhaps coming? I didn't. Surely he would not have been welcome. Well, apparently he attended the coronation under the pseudonym of Mr. Brown. Did he? And he spoke to someone in the audience and said he wouldn't want to be crowned for anything. Looked a terrible business. Really? It was reported in a newspaper.
邦妮·普林斯·查理（小王位觊觎者查理）可能也出席了的这件事吗？我没有。他肯定不会受到欢迎吧。嗯，显然他是化名为“布朗先生”潜入加冕典礼的。是吗？他还跟观众席上的某个人说，他才不愿意为了什么东西去接受加冕呢。看起来是一件极其糟糕的事情。真的吗？报纸上是这么报道的。
Yeah, it's easy for him to say that once he's lost, though, isn't it? I mean. Yeah. Ye national inquirer. Yeah. I never wanted it anyway. Yeah, so let's do George IV. So his entry into the Abbey, that's what I read at the start of this episode, rolling in and looking like a gorgeous bird of the East.
是的，既然他已经失败了，他当然可以这么说，不是吗？我是说。是的。国民问询报。是的。我本来就不想要它。好吧，那我们来讲讲乔治四世。他进入教堂的那一幕，就是我在本集开头读到的，优雅地滚进来，看起来像一只华丽的东方飞鸟。
I mean, he's all about the bling, isn't he? Yeah, he is. So I said George III was an idea, but I don't think, now I'm reconsidering that because I think George IV is pretty bad. So first of all, George IV, his coronation actually is postponed because of his marital difficulties. So it was meant to be August 1820. It gets put off by almost a year because he wants to get rid of his wife,
我的意思是，他满身都是珠光宝气，对吧？是的，他确实是。所以我刚才说乔治三世是个奇葩，但我不这么认为……现在我正在重新考虑这一点，因为我觉得乔治四世简直糟糕透顶。首先，乔治四世的加冕典礼实际上因为他的婚姻纠纷而推迟了。原本定于1820年8月举行。结果硬生生推迟了将近一年，因为他想甩掉他的妻子，
Caroline of Brunswick, who he accused of never changing her underwear in all the time he was married to her. rid of his wife, Carolina Brunswick, who he accused of never changing her underwear in all the time he was married to her. So I think it's fair to say they both behaved pretty badly, didn't they? George and Carolina Brunswick. They just absolutely despised each other. To George's credit, he's a great antiquarian. So that's the kind of interesting thing.
不伦瑞克的卡罗琳，他指责她在两人结婚期间从来没有换过内衣。甩掉他的妻子，不伦瑞克的卡罗琳，他指责她在两人结婚期间从来没有换过内衣。所以我觉得可以说他们两个人的表现都相当糟糕，对吧？乔治和不伦瑞克的卡罗琳。他们简直恨透了彼此。不过有一说一，乔治是个狂热的古物爱好者。所以这就是有趣的地方。
I suppose it's a way of elbowing the Stuarts aside, going back to the medieval coronation. So there's a kind of spirit of antiquarianism. Absolutely. And he's all about resurrecting medieval and Elizabethan looks, isn't he? Yeah. He basically says everybody must dress as an Elizabethan. So it's the first ersatz coronation. It is.
我想这也是一种把斯图亚特家族挤到一边、回归中世纪加冕礼的方式。所以其中包含了一种古物研究的热情。完全正确。而且他热衷于重现中世纪和伊丽莎白时期的风貌，对吧？是的。他基本上宣布所有人都必须打扮成伊丽莎白时期的人。所以这是第一场人造加冕典礼。确实如此。
It's the first one. Well, we've probably got about as far from the sacral now as we can ever get. It's like a panzer night. Let's do it in fancy knife. Let's do a fancy dress. That's all. So, yes, but he insists that everybody else
这是第一场。好吧，我们现在离神圣性大概已经能有多远就多远了。这就像是一场化妆舞会。让我们穿奇装异服吧。让我们搞个化装舞会。就这样。所以，是的，但他坚持要求其他人
has to pay for their own fancy dress, whereas he expects the country to pay for his. To pay for his. Because he's dressing as Napoleon.
都得自己掏钱买化装服，而他却指望国家来为他的服装买单。为他的服装买单。因为他要装扮成拿破仑。
Right. Well, he's dressing, I mean, if you look at his garb, he looks absolutely preposterous. And actually, you mentioned Napoleon. So,
好吧，他打扮得——如果你看看他的行头，他看起来简直荒谬绝伦。而且事实上，你提到了拿破仑。所以，
French war reparations actually foot a lot of the bill for this. So I worked out the cost. It was £238,000. In terms of as a proportion of GDP and whatnot, in today's money, that would be about £1.3 billion. So this is the coronation to end all coronations. It's the biggest blowout. Now he's desperate that his wife is not allowed to take part. The legislation to divorce her, kick her out has run into trouble because the Whigs have decided, it's the Whig Victoria again, the Whigs have decided to take her side because they despise George and they despise the Prime Minister, Lord
法国的战争赔款实际上支付了这笔开销的很大一部分。我算了一下成本。那是238,000英镑。如果按照占GDP等比例折算到今天的货币价值，大约是13亿英镑。所以这是一场空前绝后的加冕典礼。这是最大的一场挥霍。现在他极其迫切地想要阻止他的妻子参与其中。旨在与她离婚并将她扫地出门的立法遇到了麻烦，因为辉格党人决定——又是辉格党，这帮家伙——辉格党人决定站在她这一边，因为他们鄙视乔治，也鄙视首相利物浦
Liverpool. So Caroline does show up on the big day. She shows up with her chamberlain, Lord Hood. She has written, Lord Hood has written and says she's going to come. Lord Howard, who's running the show, has written back and said, you know. So is this another Effingham? He's a part of the family, exactly. Part of the Norfolk clan. The Duke of Norfolk is never allowed to preside over this because he's Catholic. He always has to delegate it to some member of his extended family. She pitches up anyway.
勋爵。所以卡罗琳在大日子那天真的现身了。她和她的内侍霍德勋爵一起出现了。她写信了，霍德勋爵写信说她要来。负责操办这一切的霍华德勋爵回信说，你知道的……所以这也是另一个埃芬汉姆吗？他是家族的一员，没错。诺福克家族的一员。诺福克公爵因为是天主教徒，从来不允许主持这个仪式。他总是不得不将其委托给他的某个远房亲戚。她不管怎样还是赶到了。
She arrives on the big day at six o'clock in the morning at Westminster Hall. There's a lot of people in the crowd who support her. There are soldiers guarding Westminster Hall who don't let her in. The commander of the guard says, you can't come in without a ticket. She says, I'm the queen.
她在重大日子的清晨六点钟抵达了威斯敏斯特大厅。人群中有很多人支持她。保卫威斯敏斯特大厅的士兵不让她进去。卫队指挥官说：“没有票你不能进。”她说：“我是王后。
I don't need a ticket. No good. She's eventually turned away after trying various doors. And then she and Lord Hood eventually go down to Westminster Abbey. George IV has hired a load of boxers to act as doorkeepers. So one of these boxers says to her,
我不需要票。”没用。在尝试了多扇门都被拒之门外后，她最终被赶走了。随后她和霍德勋爵一同前往威斯敏斯特教堂。乔治四世雇了一帮拳击手来充当看门人。于是其中一个拳击手对她说：
I'm not admitting, you know, you haven't got a ticket, love, you're not coming in. And eventually, surrounded by soldiers with bayonets, she is turned away while the crowds shout, shame, shame.
“我不放你进去，你知道的，亲爱的，你没有票，你进不去。”最终，在刺刀林立的士兵包围下，她被拒之门外，而周围的人群则高喊着：“耻辱，耻辱！”
And of course, Tom, as you will know, so she's turned away from her husband's coronation. She dies two weeks later. So a very poignant scene. I mean, actually, this would make a great film. I was thinking this, yeah.
当然，汤姆，正如你所知道的，她被丈夫的加冕典礼拒之门外后，两周便去世了。所以这是一个非常凄美的场景。我的意思是，这实际上会是一部极好的电影。我刚才也在想这个，是的。
I mean, it's an amazing story. Actually, the coronation of George III, I was thinking, would make a great comedy. Yeah. This would make a great tragic comedy. It would.
我的意思是，这是一个了不起的故事。事实上，我觉得乔治三世的加冕典礼拍成一部伟大的喜剧会很不错。是的。而这个故事会是一部伟大的悲喜剧。确实会。
It would. Actually, probably just a comedy. Although there are very comic elements. So George IV now arrives at his coronation. She's gone. He arrives, and he's wearing this massive costume.
其实，可能就是纯粹的喜剧。尽管其中包含着非常滑稽的元素。现在乔治四世抵达了他的加冕典礼。她已经走了。他到了，穿着这套巨大的戏服。
You know, as you said, it's very Napoleonic, sort of huge, huge and stuff and he is it's a very warm day and he's sweating i mean he's a lot he's a gentleman of size isn't he yeah what is he like 60 inch waist or whatever it is he's your fat friend he is soaked in sweat and he actually said to somebody afterwards i would not endure again the sufferings of that day for another kingdom. The actual content of the service, unlike the Elizabethan or the Stuart period, is pretty fixed at this point. There's no controversy about the content.
你知道的，正如你所说，这非常具有拿破仑风格，巨大无比，诸如此类。而且当时是个非常炎热的天气，他在流汗——我的意思是，他是一个体型庞大的绅士，不是吗？是的，他的腰围是多少，60英寸还是别的什么？他就是你的那个胖朋友。他浑身大汗淋漓，事后他甚至对某个人说：“为了另一个王国，我也绝不再忍受那一天的折磨了。”仪式的实际内容，与伊丽莎白或斯图亚特时期不同，到这个时候已经相当固定了。对于仪式内容没有任何争议。
And the arrangements go all right, but the choir go out first because of some sort of, I don't know, some communications breakdown. So as the king processes out, he has to go past all these empty benches which are covered with the choir's litter. So presumably the choir had been themselves smuggling pies and sandwiches or whatever. The procession to the banquet is a shambles because a very strange thing. It's the barons of the Sink Ports again, always causing trouble. They're allowed this time and they've got seats. They've got a canopy that they're meant to hold over George.
各项安排还算顺利，但由于某种原因——我不知道，某种通讯故障——唱诗班先退场了。因此，当国王巡游退场时，他不得不走过所有这些空凳子，凳子上到处都是唱诗班留下的垃圾。大概唱诗班自己也偷偷带了馅饼和三明治之类的东西。前往宴会的游行队伍乱成一团，因为发生了一件非常奇怪的事情。又是辛克港的男爵们，他们总是制造麻烦。这次他们被允许参加了，并且有了座位。他们有一顶本该在乔治头顶上撑着的华盖。
But George is very keen to be seen by the public. So he walks very fast to get out from under the canopy. So the poor wardens of the Sinkport are scurrying after him. They start walking fast too, and they're described, because they're trying to outpace each other, one of the spectators said they ended up with them making a somewhat unseemly jog towards the banquet. They get into the banquet.
但乔治非常渴望让公众看到自己。所以他走得非常快，想要从华盖底下走出来。于是可怜的辛克港卫兵们只好小跑着追赶他。他们也开始加快脚步，由于他们试图超越彼此，据其中一位旁观者描述，他们最终以一种相当不体面的小跑姿态走向了宴会。他们进入了宴会大厅。
Now, they've learned their lesson from the linen tapers last time. What they've put now is they've got massive wax candles and chandeliers. But because it's such a hot day, the candles melt. So all the people sitting underneath, they're being hit by wax. Wax is dripping on them. There's more horse action in this one. The Lord High Steward is the Marquess of Anglesey. Now, as the Lord High Steward, he is required to ride into the banquet
现在，他们从上次的亚麻烛芯事件中吸取了教训。他们现在换成了巨大的蜡烛和枝形吊灯。但由于天气实在太热，蜡烛融化了。所以所有坐在下方的人，都被蜡油砸中了。蜡油滴落在他们身上。这次还有更多的骑马戏码。宫廷总管是安格尔西侯爵。作为宫廷总管，他的职责是骑马进入宴会大厅
and reveal the first dish on the table. Unfortunately, he is the Marquess of Anglesey who lost his leg at the Battle of Waterloo, and he's wearing a prosthetic leg, and he can't get off his horse unaided. So it's a shambles. Pages have to come and try to unscrew his leg and get get off his horse unaided so it's a shambles pages have to come and like try to unscrew his leg and get him off his horse and everybody starts laughing and it ruins the atmosphere i think it's carry on coronation once again uh the king leaves at eight o'clock um he goes off bankrupt continues a little while once the guests are gone the crowd pour in um this time the rioting and stuff is much worse
并揭开桌上的第一道菜。不幸的是，这位安格尔西侯爵在滑铁卢战役中失去了他的一条腿，他戴着假肢，如果没有人帮忙，他根本无法下马。所以场面一团糟。侍从们不得不跑过来，试图卸下他的假腿，好把他从马背上弄下来，结果大家都笑了起来，这把气氛彻底毁了。我觉得这简直又是《滑稽加冕礼》重演。呃，国王在八点钟离开了，呃，他走了。晚宴又持续了一会儿，一旦宾客们离开，人群便蜂拥而入。这一次，骚乱和打砸抢的情况要严重得多。
than ever so the soldiers fighting the crowd over the remains of chicken legs smashed plates and all this kind of thing and it doesn't there all this isn't dispelled until about three o'clock in the morning um and the last anyone sees is some of sort of George IV's cronies who have drunk far too much having to be carried to their coaches. So it's not, it doesn't show Britain at its best. So Dominic, you, you asked me in the previous episode, which coronation would I most like to have seen? I would definitely like to have seen that one.
比以往任何时候都更加混乱，所以士兵们在人群中为了争夺鸡腿残渣、被打碎的盘子之类东西大打出手，这种情况一直持续到凌晨三点左右，最后大家看到的景象是，乔治四世的一些酒喝得酩酊大酊的密友不得不被抬进马车。所以这并不能体现英国最好的一面。多米尼克，你在上一集中问过我，我最想看哪一场加冕典礼？我绝对想看那一场。
Yeah. I think that's my top coronation. Right. Well, it's a lot better than the, so the next coronation with which we'll go in. Oh, we don't want that one. Come back and we'll do the most boring coronation of all time most boring coronation there's a tempting offer for you that is a tempting offer all right we'll see you after the break for that i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment
对。我想那是我的首选加冕典礼。没错。好吧，这比下一场加冕典礼要好得多，接下来我们要讲的是。哦，我们不要那一场。回过头来，我们要讲史上最无聊的加冕典礼——史上最无聊的加冕典礼，这对你来说真是一个诱人的提议，这确实是个诱人的提议，好吧，中场休息后见，我们将为你带来这些内容。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐歇会儿》。
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Then at the close of that solemn rite they both put on their crowns, and take their scepters in their hands, while neither of them frowns. Then robed in purple and velvet, they prepare to take their departure. The queen goes first, and the king follows after.
这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦爆料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外以及优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。然后在那庄严仪式的尾声，他们两人戴上王冠，手中握着权杖，脸上都没有一丝愁容。接着身披紫色天鹅绒长袍，他们准备启程离开。女王走在前面，国王紧随其后。
Then the king entered his beautiful coach, the sides were made of glass, especially made so that his subjects might see him pass, and he seated himself by his queen, most lovely and gay. Then the royal coach was driven by eight beautiful bays away. And the people cried, long live King Edward and his beautiful queen, declaring such a sight they had never seen and which they would remember for many a day because they had seen their king and queen on coronation day and that uh dominic is um by very much friend of the show william mcgonigal scotland's greatest poet on the coronation of
然后国王坐进了他那辆美丽的马车，车窗两侧都是特制的玻璃，好让他的臣民们看着他驶过，他与美丽而快乐的女王并肩而坐。随后，皇家马车由八匹漂亮的枣红马拉着缓缓驶去。人们高呼，国王爱德华和美丽的王后万岁，并宣称他们从未见过这样的景象，并且将在很长一段时间里铭记这一天，因为他们在加冕日见到了他们的国王和王后。而那，呃，多米尼克，这是，呃，本节目非常忠实的拥趸威廉·麦格哥纳高——苏格兰最伟大的诗人，关于
king edward the seventh and um in the first half we were listening to the the pie consumption the toilets in westminster abbey horses ar, people falling over left, right and centre, all tremendous carry on. Yeah. But from now on, coronations, they become more earnest, don't they? They definitely become more earnest. Deliberately so. And after George I, he's succeeded by his brother, William IV, who has absolutely no interest in or understanding of coronations whatsoever to the degree that he doesn't really want one at all. He would have listened to your very first episode in this series, Tom, in bewilderment and horror at the talk of the sacronature of coronations.
爱德华七世国王加冕典礼的诗作。呃，在上半集里，我们听到了关于馅饼的消耗量、威斯敏斯特大教堂的厕所、马屁股、人们左右逢源地摔倒，所有这些惊天动地的闹剧。对。但从现在开始，加冕典礼变得更加严肃了，不是吗？它们确实变得更加严肃了。这是刻意为之的。乔治四世之后，继位的是他的弟弟威廉四世，他完全对加冕典礼毫无兴趣，也完全不理解加冕典礼，以至于他根本就不想要什么加冕典礼。汤姆，他要是听到你在这个系列里的第一集，一定会对那些关于加冕典礼神圣不可侵犯的言论感到困惑和震惊。
Because he's a bluff sailor. He is a bluff sailor. So he wouldn't have had any. He was not a man for an abstract noun. I think it's fair to say. He didn't want a coronation. He was told he had to have one. His coronation happens in the run-up to the Great Reform Act.
因为他是个直率的水手。他是个直率的水手。所以他本不会办什么加冕典礼。可以说，他不是一个谈论抽象名词的人。我觉得这样说很公道。他不想办加冕典礼。但有人告诉他，他必须得办。他的加冕典礼正值《伟大改革法案》出台前夕。
So Britain is being convulsed by political controversy, and he's having to deal with that. There's sort of a battle between the Whigs and the Tories and popular unrest demanding parliamentary reform, all this stuff. And he says, listen, if we're going to have a coronation, I don't want any of the flummery. So the coronation banquet, the king's champion on his horse,
因此，英国正被政治争议所撕裂，而他不得不应对这一切。辉格党和托利党之间爆发了某种斗争，还有要求议会改革的民众动荡，诸如此类的事情。他说，听着，如果我们非要办一场加冕典礼，我可不要那些繁文缛节。所以加冕晚宴、骑马的国王卫士，
all of these splendid traditions. I despise them. I don't want them. And this is the point at which they're done away with. So basically, the spectacle is limited to some gun salutes and a couple of small processions. He wears an admiral's uniform, because as you said, he's a sailor uh with a robe over the top and the total cost is an eighth of george iv's coronation so i mean in some ways it might as well not have happened but dominic can i just read what he said um about the moment where the crown was laid on his brow to go for it it was a great moment when i actually felt the crown descending upon me and touching my temples i could could not restrain a thrill, but not of joy of awe at the responsibilities almighty God had been pleased to put upon me.
所有这些光鲜的传统。我都鄙视它们。我不要这些。这就是这些传统被废除的时刻。所以基本上，奇观仅限于一些礼炮和几场小型游行。他穿着海军上将的制服，因为正如你所说，他是个水手，外面罩着一件长袍，总花费只有乔治四世加冕典礼的八分之一。所以，从某种程度上讲，它甚至可以算作没办过。不过，多米尼克，我能读一下他关于王冠戴在额头上那一刻的言论吗？来吧。当王冠真正降临并触及我的太阳穴时，那是一个伟大的时刻，我无法抑制内心的悸动，但那不是喜悦的激动，而是对全能上帝赋予我的责任的敬畏。
So actually the sacrality does come through at the end. So he sees the error of his ways. Well, yes, I stand corrected. So that said, it's a bit of a non-event, isn't it?
所以实际上，那种神圣感在最后还是体现出来了。所以他认识到了自己的错误。好吧，是的，我收回刚才的话。话虽如此，这倒有点像是个虚晃一枪的活动，不是吗？
His coronation. Yeah. And actually even Queen Victoria, 1838, so seven years later, her coronation is still rubbish. So people often even Queen Victoria, 1838, so seven years later, her coronation is still rubbish. So people often say, oh, coronations, they're all in its order, it's Victorian flummery. But Queen Victoria's coronation wasn't really Victorian.
他的加冕典礼。是的。事实上，甚至维多利亚女王，1838年，也就是七年之后，她的加冕典礼依然很糟糕。所以人们经常甚至连维多利亚女王，1838年，也就是七年之后，她的加冕典礼依然很糟糕。所以人们经常说，哦，加冕典礼，全都是这套流程，这就是维多利亚时代的繁文缛节。但维多利亚女王的加冕典礼其实并不怎么“维多利亚”。
It was still Hanoverian. Yeah, and the Hanoverians did better coronations than the Victorians, actually, I would say. Well, the Victorians only did one. Well. That's very true. But you know the Victorian angle on this was that there was no anointing of the queen's breasts. Yes. I know you love this detail, Tom, which I find disturbing.
它依然是汉诺威式的。是的，实际上汉诺威人办加冕典礼比维多利亚人办得好，我要这么说。好吧，维多利亚人只办过一次。好吧。这倒确实。但你知道这其中的维多利亚式视角吗？那就是没有对女王的胸部进行圣油涂抹。是的。我知道你很喜欢这个细节，汤姆，我觉得这有点令人不安。
I mean, it's a kind of example of how the rituals evolve, isn't it? Right. Victorian prudery, I suppose. So the Victorian coronation, again again it's a lot cheaper than george the fourths um it's probably what are we looking at it's about a quarter of the cost um so it's more expensive than than william the fourths but it's still pretty cut price it is the first coronation it's a mass tourism event because of railways so probably up to about half a million people come down to london and there's fireworks
我的意思是，这正是仪式如何演变的一个例子，不是吗？没错。我想这就是维多利亚时代的虚伪吧。所以维多利亚时代的加冕典礼，同样，比乔治四世的便宜得多，嗯，我们看看大概花了多少钱，大概是四分之一的费用，嗯，所以它比威廉四世的要贵，但仍然算是相当便宜。这是第一场因为铁路而成为大众旅游活动的加冕典礼，因此大概有多达五十万民众来到伦敦，还有烟花
displays and there's things going on in the parks and there's hot air balloons i think that um people in workhouses are given beer to toast it are they yeah oh that's nice which is nice for them that's not very victorian giving them beer is it victorian would be encouraging them to work a little bit harder for yes overnight or something yes um sens, they have a break for sandwiches halfway through the coronation. I don't think the king will be doing that at his own coronation. And sandwiches are laid out on the altar, Tom.
表演，公园里也有各种活动，还有热气球。我想，救济院里的人们还被发了啤酒来为之干杯，是吗？对，哦，那挺好的，这对他们来说挺不错的，这可不太像维多利亚时代的作风，不是吗？维多利亚时代的作风应该是鼓励他们为……多工作一会儿，或者别的什么。是的，呃，感觉他们在加冕典礼进行到一半时，有时间休息吃三明治。我想国王在自己的加冕典礼上可不会这么干。三明治就摆在圣坛上，汤姆。
It seems very unsacral behaviour. Yeah. Again, people say it wasn't very well rehearsed. Witnesses say nobody knew what they were doing. Disraeli, who was there as a young mp said all those involved were always in doubt as to what came next and you saw the want of rehearsal and the archbishop of canterbury um wedged the ring very painfully onto victoria's finger yes on the wrong finger yeah the music was regarded uh one newspaper said a strange medley of
这看起来是非常不神圣的行为。是的。同样，人们说排练得并不好。目击者称，没有人知道自己在做什么。作为年轻议员出席的迪斯雷利说，所有参与的人总是对接下来该做什么感到迷茫，你完全能看出缺乏排练。坎特伯雷大主教，嗯，把戒指非常痛苦地硬套在维多利亚的手指上，是的，套错了手指，是的。音乐被认为，嗯，有一家报纸说这是一首奇怪的大杂烩，
odd combinations which doesn't sound very promising somebody fell the aptly named lord lord roll yes he fell down the steps he was 82 he fell down the steps he rolled right down in the words of queen victoria's diary that's hanoverian that's the one touch there isn't what he is a hanoverian if he's 82 rolling down steps and things and but generally there's not enough chaos and you know there's not enough vulgarity at Victoria's. It's shambolic and under-rehearsed and a bit shabby. And that's the reputation for kind of British state occasions, isn't it?
各种奇怪的组合，听起来并不怎么有希望。有人摔倒了，那个名字很贴切的罗尔勋爵，是的，他从台阶上摔下去了，他当时82岁，他从台阶上摔了下去，一路滚了下去。用维多利亚女王日记里的原话来说，那就是汉诺威风格，如果他82岁了还能滚下台阶之类的话，这就是汉诺威风格的一个触动。但总的来说，在维多利亚的加冕典礼上，混乱还不够，你知道，粗俗也不够。它是一团糟，排练不足，而且有点破旧。这就是英国国家庆典的名声，不是吗？
That they are seen abroad as being not very good. And the whole idea that state occasions and royal occasions are what Britain does best is something that presumably kicks in due to the influence of the empire and the need to kind of, you know, parades and jubilees and things. Although interestingly, I read something today that some bloke who worked in Westminster Abbey for sort of, you know, 80 years or something was asked of the coronations of 1902, 1911, 1937, and 1953, which was the best. And he said, oh, there's absolutely no doubt about it.
即它们在海外看来并不怎么样。而“国家庆典和皇家盛事是英国最擅长的事”这种观念，大概是因为帝国的统治影响以及对游行、庆典等的需求而逐渐形成的。不过有趣的是，我今天读到一则消息，有个在威斯敏斯特大教堂工作了差不多，你知道，80年左右的人，被问及1902年、1911年、1937年和1953年的加冕典礼哪一个最好。然后他说，哦，毫无疑问，
1953 was by far the best. You know, far better organized. You know, as time went on. Because it was on TV. So the whole world would be watching it. The whole world would be watching. I mean, they couldn't have horses, arses, and people falling down steps for that. No, they didn't do.
1953年绝对是最好的。你知道，组织得好得多。你知道，随着时间的推移。因为它是通过电视播出的。所以全世界都在观看。全世界都在观看。我的意思是，他们不可能为了那个而出现马屁股和人们从台阶上摔下来的场面。不，他们没有这么做。
Well, they sort of do go in fancy dress, don't they? I mean, actually, nobody thinks that the fancy dress they're wearing, people think of it as... What people wear to coronations. Yeah, but a lot of this is thanks to George IV's ludicrous pantomime senses of costume, isn't it? Yeah.
嗯，他们确实算是盛装出席了，不是吗？我的意思是，实际上，没有人认为他们身上穿的盛装是……人们对加冕典礼着装的看法。是的，但这很大程度上要归功于乔治四世那荒谬的滑稽剧式的服装审美，不是吗？是的。
Anyway, 1902 is Edward VII, Edward the Caressor. He has his mistresses, doesn't he, in a box? He does indeed. And he also, he's another very large man. He's not a great man for dieting, I think it's fair to say, or not an abstemious man. And he has an abdominal abscess just before the coronation, which means it has to be postponed, I think, pretty much two days before the big day. So one consequence is they've got loads of things planned for the people and they decide to go
不管怎样，1902年是爱德华七世，人称“纵欲者爱德华”。他的情妇们，是不是也在一个包厢里？他确实如此。而且他也是另一个身材非常高大的人。我觉得公平地说，他可不是个擅长节食的人，也不是个生活简朴的人。而且他在加冕典礼前夕患上了腹部脓肿，这意味着典礼不得不推迟，我想，几乎就是在重大日子到来前两天。所以其中的一个后果是，他们为民众筹备了大量的活动，而他们决定
ahead and do them anyway. So there's a coronation dinner for the poor of London, Tom. They were going to serve 500,000 dinners to Londoners. Is that the one that the maids went to? I think it probably is. That we talked about in Downton Abbey episode. It must be. They gave out, every single person was given a tin of Roundtree's chocolate. But, get this, Roundtree's had two different kinds of chocolate, some for the poor people who were attending the dinner, and some for the people who were stewards, helping the poor people.
无论如何都要继续推进这些活动。因此，伦敦的穷人们迎来了一场加冕晚宴，汤姆。他们原本打算为伦敦市民提供50万份晚餐。这就是女佣们去的那场吗？我想大概是的。就是我们在《唐顿庄园》那一集里谈到的那个。肯定是的。他们分发了，每一个人都得到了一罐朗特里（Rowntree's）巧克力。但是，听好了，朗特里公司有两种不同的巧克力，一种是给参加晚宴的穷人准备的，另一种是给那些作为服务人员帮助穷人的人准备的。
And the people who were stewards got better chocolate than the diners, because Roundtree's said they would be of greater influence socially than the poor. Well, at least I'm being honest. Well, I suppose so. But the other consequence is that a lot of the European bigwigs who are meant to be coming to this coronation had to go home. They couldn't stay around for two months waiting for people to clear up their abdominal abscesses. So as a result, it became much more British and much more imperial than it would otherwise have been. Oh, that's interesting.
而那些服务人员得到的巧克力比用餐者还要好，因为朗特里公司说，他们在社会上的影响力会比穷人更大。好吧，至少我很诚实。好吧，我想也是吧。但另一个后果是，许多本应来参加这次加冕典礼的欧洲大人物不得不回家了。他们不可能等上两个月，只为了等别人清理掉腹部脓肿。因此，结果就是，这场加冕典礼变得比原本更有英国本土特色，也更具帝国色彩。哦，这倒很有趣。
Which is interesting. So is that what then kind of instituted the idea that coronation should be an imperial occasion? I think it probably would have been a bit imperial anyway, but it's even more imperial. Yes. But I mean, that's the keynote, presumably for George V. I know nothing about George V's coronation. But I mean, it is for George VI and definitely for Elizabeth II. Yeah. For Edward VII and George V basically have the same coronation. You know, Sikh troops, Field Marshal Lord Roberts, Lord Kitchener,
这很有趣。那么，这就是奠定加冕典礼应当成为一场帝国盛事这一观念的原因吗？我想它无论如何都会带有一点帝国色彩，但现在它变得更具帝国色彩了。是的。不过我的意思是，这就是基调，大概对乔治五世来说也是如此。我对乔治五世的加冕典礼一无所知。但我的意思是，对乔治六世和伊丽莎白二世来说绝对如此。是的。对于爱德华七世和乔治五世来说，他们的加冕典礼基本上是一样的。你知道，锡克族军队、陆军元帅罗伯茨勋爵、基奇纳勋爵，
you know. But George V doesn't have his mistresses in a box. No, he doesn't. Moustaches. One nice thing actually about Edward VII's coronation is he has the
你知道的。但乔治五世可没有把他的情妇们安排在包厢里。不，他没有。小胡子。实际上，关于爱德华七世加冕典礼的一个美好的地方在于，他邀请了
commanders of the Boers along to watch a naval review. And they'd only just signed the peace deal. So he has Lewis Boater and these other characters. So they'd literally only signed the end. The end of the war was only a sort of two months earlier. And he said, oh, come to the coronation. It'd be a great laugh.
布尔人的指挥官们一起来观看海军阅兵式。而他们当时才刚刚签署了和平协议。所以他邀请了路易斯·博塔和这些其他人物。所以他们实际上才刚刚在和平协议上签字。战争结束仅仅大约两个月前。他说，哦，来参加加冕典礼吧。那会很有趣的。
You know, we can all be friends. Did they have a good time? I think they did, actually. I think they did. I mean, I don't think they go and they think, I don't think they think, oh, we've been, we've been dreadfully patronized and treated very badly there's a sort of sense oh well this is fair play well done you know hurrah for hurrah for everybody so he dies in 1910 doesn't he george v one of my favorite people from all history so i know dominic what
你知道，大家都可以成为朋友。他们玩得开心吗？我想他们确实挺开心的。我想是的。我的意思是，我不认为他们去了之后会想，我不认为他们会想，哦，我们受到了可怕的居高临下的对待，待遇非常糟糕。有一种感觉是，哦，好吧，这很公平，干得好，你知道，为每个人欢呼。所以他在1910年去世了，不是吗？乔治五世，我历史里最喜欢的人之一。所以我知道，多米尼克，
he said when his father died i've lost my best friend and the best of fathers i never had a cross word with him in my life i love george v i'm assuming that his coronation is incredibly dull he's thinking about stamp collecting of course and his creases in his trousers his wife mary way has the koinor diamond in her crown mary queen mary of ek is it tech tech tech tech i thought you'd gone mad then, Tom. So George V has this coronation. He says, it was a terrible ordeal, he writes in his diary. It was grand yet simple and most dignified and went without a hitch. What I love about George V,
当他的父亲去世时他说过什么：我失去了最好的朋友和最好的父亲，我一生中从未与他说过一句重话。我爱乔治五世。我猜他的加冕典礼一定极其无聊。他当时肯定在考虑集邮的事，当然还有他裤子上的褶皱。他的妻子玛丽在她的王冠上镶有库伊努尔钻石。玛丽，特克的玛丽。是特克吗？特克，特克，特克。我刚才还以为你疯了呢，汤姆。所以乔治五世举行了这场加冕典礼。他说，这是一场可怕的磨难，他在日记中写道。它既宏伟又简单，极其庄严，而且进展顺利。我喜欢乔治五世的地方在于，
it's not just that he's so boring. It's also that he's such a family man. He says, I nearly broke down when dear David came to to do homage to me as it reminded me so much when i did the same thing to my beloved papa so david is the future edward the eighth who is a very bad he's a he's a bounder he's a cat and a bounder so george the fourth enjoys he has a tremendous time he says he's a bit tired at the end and they must have had great coronation stamps brilliant he must have loved that so special edition stamps that he could then get for free. It's none of the banquet of vulgarity with him. Do you know what he does after the coronation for the rest of the day?
不仅仅是因为他太无聊了。还因为他是一个极具家庭观念的人。他说，当亲爱的大卫向我行效忠礼时，我差点崩溃，因为这让我想起了我当年对挚爱的父亲做同样事情的情景。所以大卫就是未来的爱德华八世，他是一个非常糟糕的人，他是一个无赖，一个花花公子加无赖。所以乔治四世玩得很开心，他度过了一段了不起的时光。他说最后有点累了，他们肯定有很棒的加冕纪念邮票，太棒了。他肯定很喜欢那个，也就是他可以免费得到的特别版邮票。在他身上可看不到任何庸俗的宴会。你知道他在加冕典礼后的一整天都干什么吗？
Does he go and shoot loads of birds? No. He goes and answers his telegrams. Excellent. Yeah, I should have guessed. Then he goes off to India for the Delhi Durbar. The Great Durbar, yes. Which I suppose is a kind of coronation, isn't it?
他去大量射杀鸟类了吗？没有。他去回复他的电报了。太棒了。是的，我本该猜到的。然后他前往印度参加德里杜尔巴（朝觐庆典）。盛大的杜尔巴，是的。我想这算是一种加冕典礼，不是吗？
It is. None of the crown jewels are allowed to leave the United Kingdom. Durbar. The Great Durbar, yes. Which I suppose is a kind of coronation, isn't it? It is. None of the crown jewels are allowed to leave the United Kingdom. Fortunately, however, India is full of jewels. Right. Yes. Have a habit of finding their way into- Indian crowns. Into British crowns. It's completely reasonable for Indian crowns to come to Britain, but obviously not vice versa. Of course. So a special imperial crown of India is made for him, and he goes off to Delhi with it. So Coronation Park in Delhi, about 60,000 people turn up. He and Mary of Teck are seated on thrones in their full gear.
是的。任何英国王室珠宝都不允许离开英国本土。杜尔巴。盛大的杜尔巴，是的。我想这算是一种加冕典礼，不是吗？是的。任何英国王室珠宝都不允许离开英国本土。然而幸运的是，印度到处都是珠宝。对。是的。它们总是有办法流落到——印度王冠上。流落到英国王冠上。印度王冠来到英国是完全合理的，但反过来显然就不行了。当然。因此，为他特制了一顶印度帝国王冠，他带着它前往了德里。所以德里的加冕公园里，大约有六万民众现身。他和特克的玛丽全副武装地坐在宝座上。
He says in his diary, I mean, it's the most amazing thing. It's the most extraordinary ritual probably in British history that this incredibly boring man who loves his stamps and worries about shooting birds and creasing his trousers. He's sitting on a throne while thousands of Indian dignitaries are queuing up to pay homage to him. Kind of princes. And he says in his diary, what he writes is, rather tired after wearing my crown for three and a half hours, it hurt my head as it is pretty heavy. And that's all he has to say. But the next day they go to the red fort uh and he and mary they go out deliberately modeled on the moogle emperors and the ceremony
他在日记中写道，我的意思是，这是最不可思议的事情。这可能是英国历史上最非凡的仪式——这个极其无聊、热爱集邮、担心射击鸟类和裤子褶皱的男人，正坐在一座宝座上，成千上万的印度贵族排着队向他致敬。各种王公贵族。他在日记中写道，他写下的内容是：戴了三个半小时的王冠后觉得有点累，它弄得我头很痛，因为它挺沉的。这就是他要说的全部。但第二天他们去了红堡，嗯，他和玛丽特意模仿莫卧儿皇帝出巡，整个仪式
modeled on the moogle emperors to receive um the the salutes of half a million people who have come to see them and then he goes and shoots something like 20 000 pheasants or something i knew that killing animals had to feature at some point. He writes in his diary, I think we went a bit too far today or something like that. So actually, George VI's coronation, I think is quite boring. I don't want to be disrespectful, but he is quite boring. So he's King's Speech, father of Queen Elizabeth II, king during the Second World War. And he shouldn't have got it because this coronation has been explicitly arranged for his brother, dear David, Edward VIII, who has deserted his post, Tom, to go off on an American divorcee.
模仿莫卧儿皇帝，接受前来瞻仰他们的五十万民众的敬礼。然后他去射杀了大约两万只野鸟之类的东西。我就知道杀生动物这一环节迟早会出现。他在日记中写道，我想我们今天可能有点过头了之类的。所以实际上，乔治六世的加冕典礼，我觉得相当无聊。我无意冒犯，但他确实挺无聊的。所以他是《国王的演讲》的主角、伊丽莎白二世女王的父亲、二战期间的国王。他不应该得到这个王位的，因为这场加冕典礼原本是明确为他的兄弟、亲爱的大卫——爱德华八世筹备的，而大卫为了一个美国离异女子，抛弃了他的职位，汤姆。
Something that we don't approve of on the rest of history. He's gone off. This is a very big empire and dominions kind of coronation. So the prime ministers from all the dominions are present for the first time in the procession. Once again, you've got tons of contingents of kind of Indian troops, Canadians, Australians, all of those kinds. Tom, you're yawning even while I'm-
这是我们在《历史歇会儿》中绝对不赞同的行为。他跑了。这是一场规模宏大的帝国和自治领风格的加冕典礼。因此，所有自治领的首相首次出现在游行队伍中。再一次，你看到了大批印度军队、加拿大人、澳大利亚人等各种特遣队。汤姆，甚至在我——的时候你都在打哈欠。
Sorry. I just thought of it. It's making me bored. So first radio coronation. So he gives an address. This is your Lionel Logue, Geoffrey Rush in the film. course of course don't stammer all this stuff uh the bbc do film and will televise the procession i mean nobody has a television so i don't know who's actually watching sort of 15 people in in surrey or something oh look there's me so exactly in
抱歉。我只是刚想到这个。这让我感到无聊。所以这是首次通过广播播出的加冕典礼。所以他发表了一讲。这就是你的莱昂纳尔·罗格，电影里的杰夫·里什。当然，当然，别结巴，所有这些，嗯，BBC进行了拍摄，并将对游行进行电视转播。我的意思是，当时根本没有人有电视，所以我不知道到底是谁在看，萨里的十五个人左右，或者别的什么。哦，看，那有我。所以完全在
the procession have you seen it no have you seen it no of course not i couldn't be less interested in it golly tom you're really uh georgia six coronation i think of all the things we've done throughout across all the entire sweep and span of our podcast what's the single most boring thing that i can think of don't you think no i don't think of anything more boring i've yes yes we recorded an episode that we never put out because it was so boring it was so boring while we were doing it i booked a holiday okay yes i know do you remember the episode yes i do yes i do that was worse than this okay but that that hasn't gone out whereas this i'm assuming
游行队伍里，你看过吗？没有。你看过吗？没有，当然没有。我再也没有比这更不感兴趣的了。天哪，汤姆，你真的是，乔治六世的加冕典礼，我想在我们整个播客跨越的所有主题、纵览的所有历史长河中，这是我能想到的最无聊的一件事，你不觉得吗？不，我想不出比这更无聊的事了。我，是的，我们录制过一期节目，因为太无聊了所以从来没播过。它太无聊了，我们在录制的时候我都订好假期了。好吧，是的，我知道。你还记得那一集吗？是的，我记得。是的，我记得。那一集比这个还糟糕。好吧，但那一集没有播出去，而这个，我假设
is going out and so i put anyway, make it interesting for the listeners. Second World War is just storm clouds overhead. Storm clouds are building. Meanwhile, in Germany. Herr Hitler. Yes, exactly. There you go. Done.
是要播出去的，所以不管怎样，给听众们讲得有趣点吧。第二次世界大战，风暴就在头顶。风暴正在酝酿。与此同时，在德国。希特勒先生。是的，完全正确。好了。搞定。
This was the second, 1953. Filmed in 3D, Tom. Did you know that? Did you know it was filmed in 3D? No, no, that is interesting. I once did. I was a talking head on a Channel 4 documentary called The Coron filmed in 3D? No, no, that is interesting. I once did. I was a talking head on a Channel 4 documentary called The Coronation in 3D. And what I was required to do was to go down and they kept saying,
这是第二场，1953年。用3D拍摄的，汤姆。你知道吗？你知道它是用3D拍摄的吗？不，不，这很有趣。我曾经做过。我是第四频道一部名为《3D加冕典礼》纪录片的访谈嘉宾。用3D拍摄的吗？不，不，这很有趣。我曾经做过。我是第四频道一部名为《3D加冕典礼》纪录片的访谈嘉宾。而我被要求做的是，去到那里，他们不停地说，
now, can you answer this question by explaining why it's really appropriate that Elizabeth II was filmed in 3D in 1953? It's very hard to answer that. But the most popular member of the procession was the Queen of Tonga. So it rained. Famously, it rained on the coronation day in 1953. It's a kind of miserable occasion because it's post-war. Britain's only just coming out of the long period of post-war austerity. So it's kind of greyness to London and a grayness to the proceedings, I would say. And it starts raining. And in Tonga, if you are somebody's guest,
现在，你能回答这个问题吗：解释一下为什么伊丽莎白二世在1953年以3D形式被拍摄是如此契合？这很难回答。但游行队伍中最受欢迎的成员是汤加女王。所以下雨了。众所周知，1953年的加冕日下雨了。这是一个相当凄凉的场合，因为那是战后时期。英国才刚刚摆脱战后长期紧缩的阴影。所以伦敦有一种灰暗感，整个活动也有一种灰暗感，我要这么说。而且开始下雨了。而在汤加，如果你是某人的客人的话，
it is regarded as impolite to imitate them in any way. So all the carriages put up their hoods. And so she didn't. And she doesn't. And so the crowd can see her. The crowd can see her. And they think she, I mean, because she's quite large and because she's kind of she doesn't and so the crowd can see her the crowd can see her and they think I mean Picard
以任何方式模仿他们都被认为是不礼貌的。所以所有的马车都升起了顶棚。而她却没有。而她没有升起顶棚。所以人群可以看到她。人群可以看到她。而他们认为她，我的意思是，因为她身材相当高大，而且因为她那种，她没有这样做，所以人群可以看到她，人群可以看到她，他们认为，我的意思是，皮卡德
because she's quite large and because she's kind of quite jolly yeah the crowd will start waving and laughing and everybody says oh the Queen of Tonga
因为她身材相当高大，而且因为她性格挺开朗的，是的，人群开始挥手大笑，每个人都说，哦，汤加女王
what a tremendous person and she is the great star yeah because she's the only person who goes to that that I know anything about well Churchill went yeah
真是个了不起的人啊，她就是最大的明星，是的。因为她是那场活动中唯一一个我有所了解的人。嗯，丘吉尔去了，是的。
I didn't know that Churchill went of course he I mean I assume he went but I don't know that Churchill went. Of course he, I mean, I assume he went, but I don't know anything he did there. He just, you know, wiped away,
我不知道丘吉尔去了。当然，他，我的意思是，我假设他去了，但我不知道丘吉尔去了。当然，他，我的意思是，我假设他去了，但我对他在那里做的事一无所知。他只是，你知道，擦去了，
yeah, he wiped away tears at the spectacle of a radiant young queen. A new Elizabethan. Exactly. Nehru went to that coronation. That's nice. Yeah, Nehru went.
是的，面对一位光芒四射年轻女王的壮观景象，他擦去了眼泪。新伊丽莎白时代人。完全正确。尼赫鲁也去参加了那场加冕典礼。那挺好的。是的，尼赫鲁去了。
But you're right. It's, it's actually a surprisingly dull occasion, though. It's really livened up by Everest. So it's on the morning of the coronation that the news reaches Britain that Sir Edmund Hillary and Tenzing Norgate...
但你说得对。这其实是一个出奇沉闷的场合。不过，因为它，气氛被珠穆朗玛峰的消息给彻底炒热了。就在加冕典礼的早晨，埃德蒙·希拉里爵士和丹增·诺尔盖的消息传到了英国……
Brought by James Morris, who will shortly become Jan Morris. Exactly so, broken in the times by James, later Jan Morris. And we'll be doing an episode on that. And we will be doing an episode about the conquest of Everest. So in the newspapers in Britain, there is this sort of enormous outpouring And we'll be doing an episode on that. And everybody says, oh, hurrah, hurrah, we're top nation once again, and all this sort of carry on. The other thing is, of course, TV.
由詹姆斯·莫里斯带回，他不久后将成为简·莫里斯。完全没错，由詹姆斯（后来成为简·莫里斯）在《泰晤士报》上率先打破新闻。我们将会做一期关于这个的节目。我们将会做一期关于征服珠穆朗玛峰的节目。因此，在英国的各大报纸上，出现了这种巨大的情感宣泄，我们将会做一期关于这个的节目。每个人都说，哦，太棒了，太棒了，我们再次成为顶尖国家了，所有这些类似的热闹。另一件事当然是电视。
Let's say 25 million people watched it on TV, and yet there are only about two to three million televisions in Britain. So people are literally cramming into their neighbors' houses to watch. And it's the single biggest, most important moment in the massive take-up of television in 1950s Britain. Because people are desperate to see this extraordinary spectacle through the miracle of television, Tom. Yes. And of course, still then, a largely Christian country, deferential towards authority. Yeah, that's true. Absolutely true. Yeah. Not much of a Republican movement then.
可以说有2500万人通过电视观看了这场加冕典礼，然而英国当时只有大约两到三万台电视机。所以人们简直是挤进邻居家里去观看。这是20世纪50年代英国电视普及浪潮中单一最大、最重要的时刻。因为人们渴望通过电视这一奇迹来亲眼目睹这非凡的奇观，汤姆。是的。当然，在那时，它仍然是一个很大程度上信奉基督教的国家，对权威毕恭毕敬。是的，那是真的。绝对是真的。是的。当时没什么共和派运动。
I mean, literally, you could probably fit it in a phone box. There are lots of people who are maybe indifferent to the monarchy or even people who think, well, I don't really like them, but there's no organized Republican movement worthy of the name.
我的意思是，字面意义上讲，你大概可以把他们全塞进一个电话亭里。有很多人可能对君主制漠不关心，甚至有人会想，嗯，我其实并不喜欢他们，但根本没有什么值得一提的有组织的共和派运动。
So quite different circumstances to today's coronation. I think the Republican movement, you could still pretty much fit in a phone box. It's about a quarter of the population. No, but that's not the same as a republican movement though is it that's no i've seen people who who regard the whole thing with contempt and you know flummery mumbo jumbo and yeah why are we paying for this nonsense maybe about a quarter of the population um i think it's just it's just you know we've've been in the first episode looking at how these rituals have long sustained a kind of deep meaning.
所以这与当今的加冕典礼环境完全不同。我认为共和派运动，你大概依然能把他们塞进一个电话亭。大约占人口的四分之一。不，但这和共和派运动不是一回事，不是吗？那不是——我见过那些对整件事持蔑视态度的人，你知道，什么繁文缛节、胡言乱语，以及“我们为什么要为这种废话买单”之类的观点，大概占人口的四分之一吧。嗯，我觉得这只是，你知道，我们在第一集中看到这些仪式如何长期维系着一种深刻的意义。
And even over the course of the past few hundred years where that meaning has been misunderstood or misinterpreted or occluded or whatever, it's still been there. And it was obviously incredibly important for the Queen. You know, she devoutly believed that it had been a sacramental moment. Yes. A bit like elizabeth the first you know she'd been married to her nation all that kind of thing yeah um i think that what's interesting about the uh operational orb it's called isn't it the uh charles's coronation is that probably most people will view it as a either with indifference they won't bother with it at all, or they'll watch it as a spectacle. Or they will be radically infuriated by the whole spectacle. Yeah.
而且，即使在过去几百年里，这种意义被误解、被曲解、被遮蔽或怎样，它依然存在。而且对女王来说，这显然极其重要。你知道，她虔诚地相信这是一个具有圣礼意义的时刻。是的。有点像伊丽莎白一世，你知道，她把自己嫁给了国家之类的事情。是的。嗯，我觉得关于那个所谓的“御球”——它是这么叫的吧，查尔斯的加冕典礼最有趣的地方在于，可能大多数人看待它的态度要么是漠不关心，他们根本不会理会它，要么就是把它当成一场奇观来看待。或者他们会被整个奇观彻底激怒。是的。
Or they will be very excited by the very sacral quality of this coronation. Tom, the group that I'm least persuaded by is the people who, like you, are convinced of the sacrality of the uh of the occasion i think there's an awful lot of people probably a majority who enjoy a spectacle i i completely agree and i think it's always been that way but the fact remains that it is a sacral occasion it it you know without that sacral occasion there's no point in having it um and people may ignore it they may despise it They may not even be aware of it, but it remains a religious service. And that is, I think,
或者他们会为这场加冕典礼本身那种极其神圣的特质而感到无比兴奋。汤姆，我最无法被说服的一个群体，就是像你这样深信这场活动的圣洁性的人。我认为有相当多的人，可能占了大多数，他们只是单纯地享受一场视觉奇观。我完全同意，而且我认为一直以来都是这样。但事实依然是，这是一个具有圣洁意味的场合，如果没有这种神圣的性质，举办它就毫无意义。而且人们可能会忽视它，可能会鄙视它，
a challenge in a country that is increasingly not Christian, not interested in religion at all. Because I think for the first time, it means that we have rituals surrounding the enthronement of our head of state
甚至可能根本不知道它的存在，但它依然是一场宗教仪式的服务。我认为，在一个越来越不信奉基督教、对宗教毫无兴趣的国家里，这是一个挑战。因为我认为这是有史以来第一次，这意味着我们围绕国家元首登基所举行的仪式，
that probably mean very little to the vast majority of people who are watching it, I would say. So I think that is something new. I would wonder deep down how much those rituals meant to lots of the people in those crowds. No, I agree. I agree. But they might not understand the theology. They might not understand the scriptural references. They might not understand the precise significance of the ritual, but they would be aware that it was significant. If you asked people, I mean, even at kind of George III or whatever, they'd say, does it matter that you have one?
对于绝大多数观看它的人来说，可能没有什么实际意义，我要这么说。所以我觉得这是个新鲜事。我很想知道，在内心深处，那些仪式对于蜂拥而至的人群中的许多人来说到底意味着什么。不，我同意。我同意。但他们可能不懂神学。他们可能不懂经文引用。他们可能不懂仪式的精确意义，但他们会意识到它是具有重大意义的。如果你问人们，我的意思是，即使在乔治三世或别的什么时期，他们也会说，举办这样一场典礼重要吗？
So the example of that is William IV. He was told he has to have one even if he doesn't want one. He was basically told he has to have one because he picks up a crown, doesn't he, or something and puts it on his head and says, I had a coronation. He gets told in no uncertain terms that you have to have it. But now I think lots of people would just be simply bewildered by what's going on. I think you've spent too much time in the metropolitan dinner parties, Tom. When I tread the streets of Middle England, I see people sobbing with joy at the thought of the coronation.
所以威廉四世就是一个例子。当时有人告诉他，就算他不想办，也必须得办。基本上有人告诉他，他非办不可，因为他拿起一个王冠，或者别的什么，戴在自己头上说，我已经办过加冕典礼了。但他被明确告知，你必须举办一场。但现在我觉得很多人会被正在发生的事情搞得一头雾水。我觉得你在伦敦的晚宴上呆的时间太长了，汤姆。当我走在英格兰中部的小镇街头时，我看到人们一想到加冕典礼就感动得热泪盈眶。
Dusting down their bunting. Exactly. Dusting down their bunting. Our next door neighbor has bunting, actually. A note of hope. Yeah. Could I end the series by quoting a tweet by Francis Young, who was- I know you like Francis Young.
掸掉他们的小彩旗上的灰尘。没错。掸掉他们的小彩旗上的灰尘。实际上，我们的邻居就挂了彩旗。这是个充满希望的信号。是的。我能以引用弗朗西斯·扬（Francis Young）的一条推文来结束这个系列吗？他——我知道你很喜欢弗朗西斯·扬。
He came on our podcast to talk about the occult. He did. Magic in Merlin's Realm. And he was very keen on all the occult significance of pavements in Westminster Abbey and things. And he tweeted, the king seems to be going hard on the sacralization of monarchy. Oil consecrated in Jerusalem. The Cosmati pavement uncovered. So that's the one in Westminster Abbey.
他曾上过我们的播客来谈论神秘学。他确实来过。关于梅林王国的魔法。而且他对威斯敏斯特大教堂地砖等等所有神秘学的象征意义非常热衷。他在推特上写道，国王似乎在极力推崇君主制的圣洁化。在耶路撒冷祝圣的圣油。科斯马蒂地砖被重新发掘出来。这就是威斯敏斯特大教堂里的那一块。
Relics of the true cross. So they were given to him, to Charles, by the Pope. The St. Augustine Gospels. So they've come from, I think, Corpus Christi College, the oldest gospels in Britain. More privacy for the anointing. This is wild. I think he's wrong.
真十字架的圣物。所以这些是教皇送给查尔斯的。圣奥古斯丁福音书。所以它们来自，我想是基督圣体学院，英国现存最古老的福音书。为涂圣油环节提供更多隐私。这太疯狂了。我觉得他错了。
I'll tell you what I think is wild. Toilets being set up in chapels, sandwiches laid out on the altar, horses coming in backwards. Sir Cheverel forever so i i'm absolutely torn between excitement at the cosmati pavement being uncovered yeah and disappointment that there isn't going to be a horse right i'm backing up to the king and showing him his ass if there's no high church riot in taunton i should be very disappointed well you can organize one i
我来告诉你我认为什么是疯狂的。小教堂里搭建了厕所，圣坛上摆着三明治，马匹倒着走进来。切弗尔爵士万岁，所以，我对科斯马蒂地砖重见天日感到无比兴奋，但同时又对没有一匹马倒着走进来向国王展示它的屁股感到失望。如果在汤顿没有发生一场高教会派暴动，我会非常失望的。那你可以组织一场呀。
could i could indeed the great riot of chipping Norton yeah get on with it right so on that bombshell Tom Coronation's actually turned out to be much more interesting
我可以，我确实可以。奇平诺顿的大暴动。好啦，继续吧。好吧，带着这个重磅炸弹，汤姆，加冕典礼实际上比我想象的要有趣得多。
than I thought we're starting the Olympics isn't it yeah I mean I compared them to the Olympics right at the beginning and I remember
我们要开始讲奥运会了，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，我在一开始就把它们比作奥运会，我记得
when we finished doing the two episodes we did in the Olympics we ended by saying well that was a lot more interesting than I thought it would be it's good to end
当我们结束我们在奥运会上做的两集节目时，我们以这样的话结尾：嗯，这比我想象的要有趣得多。以这种方式结束《历史歇会儿》的节目感觉挺不错的，而不是说，嗯，这比我想象的要有趣得多。以这种方式结束《历史歇会儿》的节目感觉挺不错的，总比以相反的方式结束要好。那比我想象的要糟糕得多。是的。所以非常感谢大家的收听。我们希望你们能过一个愉快的加冕日，无论你们是打算观看它，还是只是开溜，或者在做你们自己的事。
Restless History episodes that way rather than saying, well, that was a lot more interesting than I thought it would be. It's good to end Restless History episodes that way, rather than end the other way. That was a lot worse than I thought it was going to be. Yeah. So thanks very much for listening. We hope that you have a good coronation, whether you are going to watch it or whether you're just bunking off or doing whatever you're doing.
祝你们玩得开心。上帝保佑国王。你刚才说的是上帝保佑国王吗？上帝。玩得开心。上帝保佑国王。你刚才说的是上帝保佑国王吗？上帝保佑国王。上帝保佑国王。愿国王万寿无疆。人们都是这么说的。或者，你知道，支持革命，
Have fun. God bless the King. Did you say God bless the King? God. Have fun. God bless the king. Did you say God bless the king? God save the king. God save the king. May the king live forever. That's what people say. Or, you know, on the revolution,
如果你是这么觉得的话。我们在这里可以说是对各种政治立场都持开放态度的。所以祝你们过得愉快。是的，我们当然是。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史歇会儿》。
if that's how you feel. We're kind of, you know, we're open to all political situations here. So have a good time. Yes, of course we are. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
想要获取独家番外、抢先收听、无广告体验以及我们的聊天社区权限，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐歇会儿》。这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦爆料，在我们的问答环节中，
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A,
我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外以及优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及优先购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。